from austin to amsterdam
thank you for being here welcome back to
another edition of down the middle i'm
so excited today to bring to you a
rising star on twitter somebody who's
revolutionizing how we take in analysis
to help us find how we're going to be
positioning our portfolios
a fellow paisan i bring you alfonso
pecatello he is the founder of the macro
compass but much more importantly he
used to run 30 billion dollars and
that's really when you're talking about
who do i listen to who are my go-to
experts you want somebody who has run
money and at the same time also knows
macroeconomics so i bring to you the
best of both
very happy to have him with us
today uh it's my pleasure danielle
really big times being here it's uh it's
an enormous honor
well uh so okay your last name
peccatiello so there's a little bit of
history there we're gonna do a little
bit of geography here because
i'm a paisana okay and i can call myself
that
um
my grandmother was uh was from naples
and she had a temper boy did she have a
temper but she taught me how to cook
everything i know how to cook i i i
learned from her my grandfather was a
very calm man from guardia agrele which
is in abruzzo
close to pescara
and in 1786
my family moved to this town
from san martino
so the only reason i know this is
because i went and visited and saw the
cornerstone of my where my grandfather
was born and the house and the vineyards
and everything
and i made the mistake of saying well
they're from san martino that's where
did checho pastas made and they said no
no no no
you call yourself an italian it's di
checo pasta so when people are always
like where did it's deco pasta exactly
people are like so where are you from
and i'm like i am from san martino where
they make dicho pasta because that's
where my family came in 1786 and just
like vito corleone in ellis island
they didn't i have no idea what my last
name is
because all they said was that we were
from san martino which is my maiden name
is dimartino so that's my story where
are you from
so
you you hit really close to my heart
because i am from a small town close to
naples actually 70 kilometers away
uh it's closer to the amalfi coast than
it is to naples but for people to know
it's it's easier to stay close to naples
so pure south
a very humble family as you well know
gdp per capita is not that high over
there so we try to
you know we are happy with not much to
be honest and
[Music]
i am sad enough to say i have left italy
for work i went to the north of europe
to germany first then to the netherlands
but my heart is still there i mean i
can't i can't get around that i visit
there probably you know four or five
times a year at least maybe six
and married to a southern italian lady
of course because it can't be otherwise
no
baking my baking my sourdough bread and
pizza from time to time oh i'm jealous
i'm jealous
and cooking you know proper italian
stuff and you know it's
people from the south of italy are just
very spontaneous they they're very open
they uh they're warm and they are just
what they are nothing to hide
well i i think that i got all of what
you described then from my grandmother's
side so when i when i go to italy i go
straight to florence
and it's just it's it's like there's a
magnet between me and i went as far as
rome on my most recent trip i went a few
months ago to italy and it was just i
was so happy that everything was still
intact and that the people were still as
warm and wonderful as they've always
been i love my home country um
so
humble beginnings your father
taught you a story about humility
uh
and without using the actual word can
you kind of quote him i mean
we have young viewers alfonso we have
younger years so what was your father's
wisdom
some background first my father is a
forklifter
um working on a
non-permanent sort of temporary rolled
contract every year so it's really tough
you always have to hope they're gonna
call you back next year or you are
unemployed in a place that has a 40
unemployment rate so good luck
so he's the you use the past of the verb
but he still teaches me humility every
day and one of his best quotes is um
okay let me not try to use the literal
word but
uh
success taste is much better
if you before have gone through some
trouble let me say like that but he says
if you have eaten some some fill in the
blank then success always tastes tasty
stuff before right so if you've gone
through some some trouble in life
and you have been toughened up by it
then normally when you are successful
this is even better
i couldn't agree more i mean well i i we
both come from very humble beginnings
and uh
in the united states i say i started off
in community college and everybody kind
of understands
where i'm coming from but uh but i
appreciate humility and people who make
their way out of it and make their way
so you're the italian dream
um
so
talk me through
what that bad taste was seven years ago
so basically seven years ago i was
involved in a
deadly car accident i'm still here so
supposed to be deadly um
it was a frontal car accident at a very
high speed between two cars which
normally means you're dead
and i suffered a lot of injuries
was trapped into the car wreck for hours
before the firefighters could could
bring me out of it
it's very intense he'll have goosebumps
to be honest talking about it um and
from there a very tough journey started
because i was lucky to be alive that's
true but i had to endure years of uh
surgeries and like we were talking like
big stuff uh trying to recompose bones
back bones leg bones and all of that
for five years in a row so we're talking
like you did the first surgery to try
and reconstruct they fully open your leg
and then physio wheelchair
and all that stuff and then nine months
later you knew already you had to go
through another one so all over again
all over again and with no certainty
you're actually gonna be able to walk at
all after that if not even to to try and
run and do some sports but you had no
alternative right so that's what the
the you know the the family teachings
come useful for because you can only try
to fight in that situation and also
you're forced into it you don't have a
choice rather than to be humble and
literally try your best
believe in yourself do some hard work in
physio and maybe you're gonna get there
plus some luck which i had so ultimately
they fixed me right and that's what
matters the most because after a lot of
fighting uh five years you know they
managed uh together with me and at the
end of the day i can now walk and even
and look the fact that i'm saying i can
walk rather than run a marathon
um tells me that it's been um yeah well
at the end of the day good to go through
that experience because you start having
a different perspective
walking is already something it
basically humbles you because you have
no other alternative than to fight
to get to
to something right and something is
walking and that something this is even
better if you have gone through some
crap first right of course and i mean
and when you think about
the the human being the physiology i
mean to us to most people walking is
like breathing it's something we just
take for granted
and and once you've lost that so i i
completely i mean i'm i'm amazed by your
story i i applaud your courage
um
my father taught economics and finance
when i was a little kid i used to read
the wall street journal and i had no
idea what it was saying and
but
i grew up with it so you also grew up
in the world of money and banking
finance economics yeah we have some
pretty similar stories i hear a
background so
i said my father is a forklifter my
mother
works in a uh in a small italian bank
she's the treasurer of that bank
which means a lot of um
btp italian government bond future
charts on your lunch table where you're
eating your pasta when you are 14 and
you're like mom why are we looking at
this thing i mean what the hell is that
chart and why
yeah of course well we have lunch
angie's like you know
the btp market never sleeps i'm like
what the hell is the btp market and so
she will go like btp stands for uh
whatever it stands in italian for and um
and you know this is the italian
government bond market this is the
future that there's an underlying of
like stop their
government bond future what the hell are
you talking about and then you know you
get interested because she's a
basically as your grandmother as you
said before a very uh typical southern
italian lady with a lot of passion for
what she does and
so very self-explanatory as we from the
south of italy are sometimes and you
know you get passionate about it and
plus i was always curious lucky enough
to be since i was a kid so ultimately my
journey in finance started when i was
probably 14 to 15
with these
lunch breaks effectively
so btp's um let let's go there for a
minute because
you know it wasn't that long ago you
know i mean well it was well i'm getting
old so it was like 10 years ago we were
kind of veering into the euro crisis
and uh everybody talked about btps
everybody it was it was kind of like the
subprime index that people would follow
is it it's like is is europe going to
blow up or not and the prism that you
followed
was that market
so
go go back 10 years talk about that talk
about the italian banking system
and
what's happened since then and what's
not happened i think more importantly
since then
a great question so
uh
basically
the btp market was about to implode
somewhere in to late 2011 beginning of
2012.
because of the construction of the
european monetary and fiscal system
right which is very different from the
u.s one because while there is a
european central bank that sets policy
for
18
or 27 actually if you want to enlarge
different countries
uh every country is more or less free to
engineer their own fiscal policy within
a certain framework which is the
maastricht framework and the european
rules but every country more or less can
redirect resources and spend or do
deficits or less deficits at their own
will which means that fiscal policy and
monetary policy are definitely not
coordinated at the european level much
less so at a country level and so
as well countries joined the european
union under very different circumstances
so italy always had a relatively healthy
private balance sheet
uh italian
the italian private sector is very
conservative never got leveraged too
much there is not a leveraged culture in
italy when it comes to the private
sector there is definitely one when it
comes to public sector so italy entered
the euro system with a pretty healthy
private balance sheet not a not so
healthy public balance sheet in other
countries in the north of europe for
example i can make the example of the
netherlands which is a very healthy
country when it comes to public debt but
it's a has a very leveraged private
sector that is you know really in that
towards the real estate market for
example it's pretty it's pretty
important here that the real estate
market holds together in the netherlands
as well they have a lot of assets in the
private sector when it comes to pension
funds private pension funds which
initially do not do not exist so it's a
very diverse setup but the fact you you
enter this union under very different
circumstances and the fact that there is
a very
diverse fiscal policy while one monetary
policy needs to be applied to 18
different countries
leads to some difficulties here and
there in europe and also some tough
decision making
so in 2011 2012
with the sovereign debt crisis the
so-called pigs so portugal ireland
italy greece and spain
were basically
attacked by markets and trying to be
broad on their knees
and
well back then what we did in italy
was uh what we call la crime esangue
which is
tears and blood policy so austerity full
stage
so effectively italy decided to punish
its private sector which wasn't
at all leveraged so they went even
further into a deleveraging process in
the private sector to try and transfer
resources back to the public sector and
convince investors that italy could
actually
uh hold their ground right
and this was a terrible blow to an
already damaged italian private sector
that basically never got access to
credit and when it did danielle it got
access to credit at very expensive
levels well plus i mean you i mean
for viewers who don't understand the
dynamic maybe you could maybe you could
make it very simplified
uh
the the the competitive advantage that
germany has compared to the
manufacturing sector which people don't
appreciate how
wonderful the manufacturing how strong
the manufacturing sector is in italy how
deep the roots go but maybe you can just
explain
kind of the dynamic with with the euro
and how that impacted well before 2011
uh
the private sector in italy
well so basically the euro is one
currency that is supposed to serve the
means and the needs of 18 different
countries in europe and germany
effectively has been accumulating
surpluses as a result of the euro the
euro is a currency that is let's say
weight were artificially cheap compared
to what the deutsche mark would be and
the result of that is that germany which
is an let's say export oriented country
is able to lever on on a currency that
is intrinsically more cheap than the
deutsche mark would be
effectively and it's therefore able to
export and to be much more productive
quote-unquote than other south
especially southern european
jurisdictions in europe would be
if they had their own their own currency
if they could devalue their own currency
at their own needs so effectively the
euro is way too
strong for southern european countries
and way too cheap for german and some
other northern european countries that
as a result are accumulating surpluses
and this is also leading to something
that is not not very often discussed
about which is target two balances so
there are different central banks in
europe and they settle payments on
behalf of uh investors and people within
countries so basically there is a system
where if i want to transfer money or buy
or move my money from germany to italy
for example i will have the on my back
the bank of italy and the german central
bank that will basically settle the
payments between italy and germany cross
country right and when they settle
payments because there is one central
clearing system at the end of the day
which is the european central bank
those
payment mismatches will result in the
so-called target 2 balances so if money
is flowing towards italy on a net net
basis from
germany then this target 2 balances tend
to basically balance out otherwise some
imbalances are created
and when you have obviously a country
that is able to accumulate much more
surpluses than another is then these
imbalances in general tend to widen a
lot
and when this imbalance is wider than a
lot this basically means that if europe
would decide to
dismantle tomorrow there will be germany
claiming
some money from italy to settle this
imbalance basically between the two
central banks right so it's a very weird
system where it where germany's get
germany and the north of europe are
getting benefits of an artificial
cheap currency compared to what it would
be neutral for them to have but at the
same time if they would decide to walk
away or italy would decide to walk away
then germany and other northern european
countries would be left with the bill to
settle or to be settled from southern
european countries that those countries
probably can't afford so it's a very
weird mechanism in here where you have
winners and losers but at the same time
you have an incentive scheme for europe
to hold together at the end of the day
both for geopolitical reasons and also
because
this weird system has been used for so
long that it's now weird enough that the
only
geopolitically sensitive thing to do is
to keep it together
and yet we hear in especially in the
western media that that germany is
supporting italy and that's something of
of a mischaracterization
and i don't i don't think there's a good
enough appreciation of this so
well the other thing i always uh try to
uncover is
people tend to look at the public sector
only that's the reference for market and
economic commentators they look at that
to gdp
government that to gdp
now if you take
say germany let's make the example of
germany and then you take together with
the government that you also take the
private sector that and most importantly
you take the so-called contingent
liabilities what the heck are contingent
liabilities
those are
germany going to kfw that is their
let's say
government agency bank
so it's basically a fully backed
development bank that lends to several
entities in germany right
now the trick is that the debt
accumulated by kfw is not
incorporated in government bond
calculations so despite there is
effectively an explicit guarantee almost
an explicit guarantee
the debt of this
bank doesn't get calculated into germany
explicitly to gdp but it's only added
bilaterally in a footnote which is
invisible called as contingent liability
now if you sum up the private sector
debt contingent liabilities and
government debt you will end up at
countries like germany and the
netherlands having similar debt ratios
to the countries in the in the south of
it or in the south of europe
and
obviously this debt is distributed in a
different way right i mean the
contingent liability is an accounting
trick but private versus public it's a
very different distribution of this debt
right and the other question you should
ask yourself is how productive this debt
is and truth to be said in italy it's
not really productive so when we incur
in that most likely we use it for
non-very productive long-term
investments and the countries in the
north of europe have done a bit more but
my point is if you look at the whole
picture instead of only looking one side
of the coin the public or the private
and you're counting the accounting
tricks called contingent liabilities
the situation is not that different as
mainstream media wants to picture no
it's not and now i've learned something
i've learned that germany has its own
fannie and freddie uh which is pretty
incredible and that's how they that's
how they account they don't calculate
public debt in the united states that to
include these two huge mortgage
guarantors and yet
they have the implicit backing of the
united states government and that is a
very well-known fact so now i've i've
totally learned something
um
why then if the private sector was not
so levered in italy why do we hear about
the oldest bank on the planet being at
risk of going away what's happened with
the italian banking system yes i think
we're going back to the btps
yeah yeah so the italian banking system
i'm sorry you asked that before and i
forgot to reply no so
the italian banking system danielle is a
here we go this is a very unproductive
system
the incentive scheme there is even
probably worse than the average
incentive scheme in the banking system
which is pretty poor but let me
elaborate so italian banks have
accumulated over the last 10 years a
record amount of npl
as a percentage of their asset side npl
is an autonomous which stands for
non-performing loans
those are loans that are classified in
accounting
as well not performing according to
certain standards so if you're
basically if your borrower doesn't pay
you back a full amount within x months
then you go into a certain category then
you move into another category if you
are
even less likely to pay etc etc now the
point is why
how did italian banks manage to get so
many of these non-performing loans on
their balance sheet right
and there are uh anecdotal examples or
empirical examples i can bring
basically the credit checks that italian
banks were doing up until 10 20 years
ago were almost non-existent and on top
of that a decent level of corruption
also places role here so credit was
channeled towards places where either
there were very little background checks
for credit worthiness
and or
there were let's say
uh personal interests in where to
redirect credit especially because the
italian banking system was extremely
populated by very small local banks
those very very small local banks in the
italian case
even in the north of italy i should say
there are plenty of cases of small
regional italian banks in the north of
italy that have defaulted because of
this reason or anyway i've gone out of
business
there was an incentive to try and
redirect credit where it was convenient
for people to redirect credit rather
than where it was
economic
for
economically sound for the bank to
direct credit that's one and then the
lack of general credit checks
led to a lot of npls on the balance
sheet and mpls are toxic for a couple of
reasons
the first is they get impaired and when
they get impaired what happens is that
you have basically to
look at losses coming over the next 10
years are you going to amortize losses
on your loans
and when you look at losses over the
next 10 years you as a bank will not be
incentivized to extend more credit it's
it's a it's a reflexivity problem it's a
scar on you if you know that by lending
over the next 10 years after receiving
regulatory scrutiny somebody finds out
you're full of non-performing loans they
force you to haircut and to face losses
over the next 10 years trust me you will
not lend money and when you don't lend
new money even if people actually
deserve it
you do not create new credit you are not
transferring to the italian private
sector you are not giving them access to
credit when you don't give access to
credit it's very difficult for
people to
participate in what i call the wealth
illusion effect yeah i mean if you
if you don't prune a rose bush and you
leave the dead wood on the rose bush
then you're not going to have roses
so and that's what that's what you're
describing
yeah and and you know
if you if you then move to the north of
europe or to the us
access for the private sector to credit
is abundant it's extremely simple and
it's abundant
and what this leads to is
for instance mortgages so if if people
want to buy a house that costs 500 000
euro and they do not have the money for
doing so what they do is they go and ask
for a mortgage which is credit being
redirected to the private sector by bank
with the collateral behind
and if this credit is delivered
with you know a certain fluidity and the
the real cost of this credit so
real interest rate on mortgages adjusted
for inflation is actually low people
will have an appetite to borrow because
their monthly installment compared to
the disposable income is except
acceptable due to the fact that
borrowing costs in real terms are pretty
low and the real salaries perhaps grow a
bit over time so they feel comfortable
and they buy the 500 000 euro house and
then if you expand new credit at lower
real interest rates this time as
mortgage costs you know you tend to go
down a bit in your in your jurisdiction
and salaries increase a bit the next guy
can buy it for 550 the next guy can buy
it for 600. well that's the basically
the wealth illusion effect we've been
creating by
lowering
real borrowing costs on mortgages in
this example so that the basically the
value today the net present value of the
asset you're buying the house can be
higher on paper as your borrowing costs
have gone down your real salary has gone
up so you can afford to buy a more
expensive house the guy who has bought
it before you has just printed 50 or 100
000 capital gains and so on and so forth
well in italy none of this wealth
illusion effect has gone on because the
private sector actually doesn't get
access to credit creation in the first
place
well and and it's interesting you bring
that up because here in the united
states we have an entire the largest
generation here the millennials
that you know when you bring up the
subject of buying a home they think
you're they think you're telling them a
bad joke because even with mortgage
rates at record lows or near record lows
they still can't make the payment work
so they just they've just factored it
out of their their future dream and they
spend all of their income
uh as opposed to trying to save up to
buy a home and at the opposite end of
the spectrum
italy has the most undervalued
residential real estate sector in the
world practically and and this is i'm
i'm going i need to buy a house in italy
this is this is this is on my to-do list
so on my to-do that's where i need to
retire
um but
but you see
how access to credit can make the
pendulum swing too far to one side which
is the case in
in the united states but much more so in
as you say the netherlands australia new
zealand canada
um and i don't think people have a good
enough appreciation for
the risk in these countries of a balance
sheet recession
yes which is what the united states
suffered after its subprime crisis and
balance sheet recessions don't end
quickly
no
and there is a fantastic book on on
balance sheet recessions which i think
it's even called balance sheet
recessions by richard kuh and he talks
about the japanese balance sheet
recession
and i always bring japan to the table
because they have basically tried this
monetary fiscal experiment already 20 25
years ago and i and of course there are
differences between japan the us and you
when it comes to
um current account balance for example
or a certain culture in their in their
society but big picture what they had
done back then danielle is effectively
create credit like there is no tomorrow
so there were a concerted effort both
from banks and from the government of
japan the government printed deficits
year after year which means they
effectively transferred resources to the
private sector
it can be in any forms they either cut
taxes
so people have more disposable income or
they send well steamies to make it
us-wise they didn't send stimulus back
then but you know it's just to say the
government basically redirect resources
to private sector but the private sector
also pays a credit spread on top
so when you ask for a mortgage you don't
get the 30-year treasury yield you get
the third year treasury yield plus a
credit spread
so if if real interest rate on a
risk-free turn close to zero and you
overlay a credit spread of one percent
on top let's say you're paying one
percent real borrowing costs as a
private person
well if you have if you're leveled up to
here and your real wages are not going
up i'm sorry but the whole castle just
comes down
and that's what happened in japan and
then you're right because it's balance
sheet leverage that leads to a balance
sheet recession
the balance sheet recession is extremely
difficult to fight
because the private sector gets hurt
banks learn that extending credit over
credit over credit to the private sector
leads them to have big trouble
so they become conservative and they act
cyclically the wrong way so actually
they start to behave pro-cyclical rather
than anti-cyclical which means when the
balance sheet recession happens
banks do not step in to land they
actually close their doors and they're
like sorry guys
you already messed it up once we are not
going to do this again
and the government
tries to offset sometimes and do some
kind of cyclical fiscal policy but also
cannot do all the heavy lifting itself
it then becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy and then as you don't extend
your credit and the private sector is
going through the leveraging the
leveraging becomes more severe
and it has long lasting impact on
unemployment and etc yeah no i mean you
you you perfectly describe an adverse
feedback loop i mean to a t
and the only exception to the rule the
sole exception to the rule is if you
have a reserve currency status
and that is i would argue why the united
states was able to come out of its
balance sheet recession
i mean if you compare it to
how many lost decades in japan
but the united states was able to come
out of its balance sheet recession
because it has the world's risk-free
treasury it has the world's risk-free
security um
but here we are today and
we're talking about sea changes at least
i'm talking about sea changes um so
let let's go
let's go down all the way to your
philosophy the macro compass
what is your what what what is your
compass i i'll tell you mine first
the move index to see what the
volatility is in the bond market and the
tren and the yield curve that's it
people like if you were on a desert
island and that's you had a bloomberg
terminal with only two
functions
dot dot go it would be the yield curve
and the move index and that would tell
me everything that i needed to know
about the u.s economy and how vulnerable
it is
what's your compass
my compass has two metrics and it's also
pretty simple on the x-axis you have the
credit impulse on the y-axis
you have the monetary policy stance
relative to neutral okay so
maybe with the bloomberg terminal you
won't do it unless you created your
functions but but we can still get there
with two functions well we can get there
because i know you and i get i get your
graphs
and we'll pop one up right here when you
send it to us anyways continue sorry
so credit impulse the first one and the
most important
our system is created on credit growth
as i said before we feed a wealth
illusion we bring forward future
consumption by borrowing more and more
why do we do that because if we wouldn't
do that we would have to revert back to
structural trend growth
trust me that's bad that's the result of
working age population growth and
productivity working age population
growth is bad because simply we are not
making kids and we are growing older so
sorry but actually the labor force is
shrinking all over the world
and the us is just barely above zero
percent thanks to some immigration
that's the first part the second part
would be productivity which is also you
know stagnating around one percent a
year one and a half percent so if you
wouldn't create any credit you would
grow at a whopping amount of about one
percent maybe tiny less wow i get just
just ask yourself which politician or
policymaker would accept
that trend growth
to be you know re-elected or to be
a trend growth which is socially
acceptable
not many especially since 1971 as we
have left the gold standard and we have
this new fantastic system it's a fully
elastic credit system you create credit
or you print deficits if you are the
government you have no fixed price at
which people can take this newly created
currency and convert it to something
which is was gold back then
there is no fixed price to convert
anything against anything
there is an embedded
um let's say peg as i call it because if
you look at of course
uh all asset prices against the currency
itself they have
all gone up which is a result of you
know this credit creation obviously gets
then recycled into assets but that's a
soft bag between 1944 and 1971 is a hard
one to respect which obviously guess
what at some point didn't work anymore
and we had to abandon that
back to the credit impulse we therefore
create credit it's a feature of the
system it's not something we want to do
it's just we do it because it works
and when we create credit the reason why
i don't look at credit creation is
because it's a feature of the system
what i look at is the the rate of change
of this credit creation so are we
accelerating are we pumping credit at a
fast pace or are we pumping credit as at
you know the slower pace
if we're pumping it at a very fast pace
i created this g5 credit input metric
it's a prop metric
you plot that
you give it 6 to 12 months time lag so
you first block that and then you say
credit impulse tell me what earnings are
going to be in 12 months
tell me what if commodities are going to
over perform
gold or not
and he tells you
i'm just kidding now but it does a very
good job at predicting where things are
going to be in terms of earnings
economic activity asset performance it's
very simple if you pump credit very fast
to the private sector you give it six
months they start using it earnings go
up
cyclical stock sectors perform
industrial commodities perform em
performs et cetera et cetera
you do the opposite you reverse the
cycle you give it six months and there
is no new credit flowing through the
economy and bonds perform and inflation
comes down and earnings come down and
defensive side of the sector of the sec
the defensive sectors of the equity
market actually were performed so that's
the first one the first metric
and the second one is the relative
monetary policy stance because as you
said both yield curve implied volatility
in bonds is extremely important i
compare that to neutral and neutral is
my estimate for well there are models
out there too but it's it's a model
estimate of what can the economy take in
terms of fed funds rate to run at
potential
you know it's of course not observable
you need to measure that right and then
you compare federal funds rate and where
they're going as well so it's not only
the the the absolute
uh different the relative difference
between fed funds rate and the
equilibrium rate but also the pace of
change
so how fast are we signaling tightening
or easing to the market that's also very
important you put these two metrics on a
compass and you obtain four simple
quadrants and you can get an asta
location indication that's it
so um
but if if if i've been reading you
correctly uh since i discovered you
which was a great discovery uh there the
law of diminishing returns plays a very
big role in the magnitude of the credit
impulse so
the impulse has to grow as a factor of
time it cannot just you can't just ramp
it up to 100 miles an hour and leave it
there you actually the next time around
you have to you have to you have to
drive at a faster speed
yes
it's basically uh dr lacy lacey hunt
one of one of his main pieces
is perfectly right i the way i
illustrate this to people who follow me
is i take the us debt to gdp i invert it
and i say okay let's look at the last 20
years for example
and then you look at
30 year real interest rates and you plot
these two series so remember you
inverted that to gdp which means if it
goes down
then
if the correlation hold real rates also
have to go down
it's one on one it's just one on one you
just plot it but again it's not because
i discovered something new it's because
that's how it works if you need to pump
additional new credit at a faster speed
to obtain a lower and lower
return when it comes to gdp growth and
earnings
this credit needs to be cheaper and
cheaper for the whole system to hold
together and that credit is cheaper only
if risk-free real interest rates are
going down and credit spreads are very
tight that's the only way you can do
that
so look at the financial condition index
of the fed i mean what do they have in
there they have
the curve shape what you look at real
interest rates credit spreads
does it equities you not much so this
financial condition index needs to
remain low and the ability for it to to
basically
uh well become less ease or tighten up
is lower and lower the ability for this
financial condition to reprice um you
know in a more restrictive way is lower
and lower as time goes by because the
entire system becomes more and more
leveraged
well and i think that that's something
that uh that jay powell
discovered the hard way
in 2018 2019
uh you know he was endeavoring to
normalize to
a fed funds rate that was impossible
he wanted to get to three percent
and he found out that three percent
would break the system
and that he couldn't get there but you
know if if it was his predecessor ben
bernanke it might have been four percent
for for it and and now here we are today
trying to figure out
you know how much
latitude the fed has despite everybody's
talking so big about eight interest rate
hikes or seven or five or four in 2022
i'm like i'll believe it when i see it
yes well the other chart that i have
that is pretty interesting to see
is
if you look at
what the bond market has been telling
you
the federal reserve terminal rate can be
so at the end of each hiking cycle
projected say four to five year forward
that was the average length of a hiking
cycle let's say four years down the road
what was the bond market telling you the
terminal rate at the end of the cycle
could be
and then you look at this chart which i
plotted we can try to stream it on so
it's like okay in 2013 this was four
percent cool
in
2015 i think this was
three and a half percent in 2018 when
powell said we are long way from neutral
you know way to go
the bond market was telling you
i'm sorry but it's probably three
percent do not try that much more than
that or that's not gonna work okay cool
now the bond market has been telling you
consistently you can't even make two
percent
and why is that because the level of
private and public sector that in the
system has increased materially
while
the capacity from private sector
especially to generate structural cash
flows earnings wage growth
that is able to service this additional
amount of debt it's just not there
well it's there but to a very little
extent so the only way for the system to
hold together
is if it's the terminal rate
is lower and lower and lower
so there is no regime change i'm sorry
but every time in my career i've heard
this probably
five times already
so i i plot third year government bond
deals i put them in a channel it's a
downward trending channel
for a good reason which is the one i'm
explaining and then around this trending
line we have some of these you know
these curvatures and these cycles right
and every time you reach the top of the
band of the very clearly downward
trending band you hear that there is a
regime change it's either the commodity
super cycle or it's the taper tantrum or
in 2018 we discover that the us economy
can deliver three percent sustainable
growth forever or you know you name it
i've heard so many of these regime
changes
and every time as you hit
what basically the bond market is
telling you there is a
lower and lower terminal rate and if you
hit the band towards the terminal rate
you have to reprice down there is no
other way otherwise cred new credit
creation is not cheap enough for the
system to lever up again and produce a
new wealth illusion effect that lets me
believe the house i bought in the
netherlands is a good investment despite
i paid it 40 more than a few years ago
because i'm borrowing at 150 basis point
lower real rates than the guy did 10
years ago that's actually the only
difference plus real wages go up but by
this the leverage effect of lower
borrowing costs so large
that it cannot reverse
so i i i
i'm going to throw this out there i
think that the difference between
where we are today
and and where we were in 2015-2016
i think you can fill in that blank with
one country china
and in 2015 2016 the the the world was
in an industrial recession
i would argue that uh the time
bit time your interview airs we will be
recognizing that we're an industrial
recession
um and that that could be a global
phenomena
but this time i don't think china comes
to the rescue and i think that some of
your work has illustrated this
yeah so
china
and you're perfectly right danielle
china has been the engine of credit
creation throughout my career
yeah yeah i mean it's impressive if i
decompose my chinese credit impulse for
the percentage of who is delivering what
all over the world in terms of credit
china has been the overwhelming majority
of what's been delivered in terms of new
credit it's been gigantic i cannot
define it otherwise well i get
i i'm going to interrupt you for a
minute and somebody on youtube just sent
me a hate mail i promise just because i
interrupted you
i don't think most people in the world
know that the four largest banks on
planet earth are in china they're like
no that's got to be jp morgan chase and
i'm like actually no no
no and and this is so important danielle
what you're saying the other thing to
understand is that the chinese system is
completely different from ours
banks create credit
every time they extend the loan they
literally print money all right so this
is the commercial banking system telling
you you don't have money to buy the
house
here you go and i'm not taking a deposit
that i'm lending every time i land i
create a new deposit that's how the
commercial banking system works in china
they have the power
to say
a state-owned huge bank
now i want you to expand credit and to x
y and z sectors please tomorrow actually
without the police i think they do it
without the police i think they do it at
one point so different yes kind of a
time just do it
and it's done and it's done in the size
they want to the sectors they want that
allows them to turn on the credit
creation
uh tabs extremely quick
and when they decide to do so in size
and quick
the result is very clear the chinese
private sector get access to
a huge amount of newly created credit
they spend it both on domestic and on
external assets and therefore the whole
world gets lifted by this huge tide that
lifts the whole boats
2015-16 your example perfectly on point
they created a huge amount of credit
2017-18 so as i said before you have to
leave it a little bit of a time lapse
for this credit to feed through the
economy 2017
strongest concerted global growth we had
seen for five years in a row even europe
managed to grow three percent in a year
i mean real gdp wise that's incredible
for us europeans that's awesome
uh
today
the situation has been very different
china has not been extending any
meaningful credit on a credit impulse
basis on a rate of change of credit
they've actually decelerated pretty
aggressively compared to a few years ago
and they have de-leveraged the private
sector very clearly xi jinping has gone
after jack ma
the entire tech ipo sector
online education sector and now the
property sector
so he has basically been saying this
sector private sectors sorry guys you
need to deleverage
for a bunch of reasons but i will force
you to de-leverage and everground has
been the the last example
now this deleveraging is pretty intense
and we will see the negative effects of
this at least throughout the first half
of 2022.
so people that are talking about the
kraka boom in nominal growth this year
sorry i can't see that
the us is not printing new credit since
march 2021 this is the last
large fiscal stimulus
banks are
very timid in lending they have
restarted a bit not much
europe as always is you use less on
credit creation but china the monster
component has been deleveraging for the
entire 2021. so in the first half of
2022 we are likely to see some
disappointment in earnings and nominal
growth data and i'm also going to argue
that
yeah probably this inflation is going to
come down pretty aggressively my models
point to numbers that by september 2022
are gonna just help out the fed not to
over tighten because the
nominal growth and the impulse of growth
and inflation throughout the economy is
going to slow down so much i believe
that they probably will just be forced
to hike much less than what the bond
market is expecting as a result i went
out yesterday and i said i am long bones
so i um
i bought 10-year treasuries at 185
percent which might some
seem crazy but to me
long-term medium investor
maybe they go to two percent sure but i
can hardly believe that we're gonna see
anything higher than that
no and i think that i think that if
there's anything that that people are
not paying close enough attention to
it's
the magnitude of the fiscal impulse in
the united states was so big that it
became its own global phenomena but
we're in a we're in a very contentious
election year in the united states so
the follow-through is not coming and
united states politicians sound like
they've lost their minds because they're
saying that the fed needs to tighten and
tighten tomorrow and yet we know looking
through the lens especially because of
china and what it's not doing for the
global economy
we know that there's a slowdown coming
it's just people aren't recognizing it
because they're seeing what the cpi
print was what this consumer price index
was last month or what it's going to be
next month because of car prices that
it's it's it's
we're in a terribly
tumultuous time i think right now and
it's very difficult for people to make
calls like you made but i think you're
exactly right
well to be honest danielle i am also a
very honest person so if i'm wrong i
always put stops to my investment ideas
i can be as right and as wrong as
anybody else i always say i'm right 53
to 54 of the times that's what i'm right
for as long as i'm right big times and
wrong stopped out little then that works
for me but to be honest i always try to
call what i see and my credit impulse
global credit impulse metrics as you
said went through the roof in 2021
because the us did so much it's it's
gargantuan i've never seen something
like that from china i've seen it
occasionally but from a developed market
uh you know jurisdiction i've never seen
so much credit being pumped no i mean
we're talking about we're talking about
10 trillion dollars here i mean it's a
big
big figure government went ballistic
absolutely ballistic and private
commercial banks actually also land on
top because that government guarantee
for some of these loans so they they
felt you know enticed to lend to the
private sector because you know the
government was back in the credit losses
in case so who cares we can lend out
right the combination
was extremely extremely strong
people like the fiscal sugar rush they
forget there is a credit cliff too and
now we're facing the credit cliff and
china is not picking up the tab as we
used to see and we saw in 2015-26
as a result my model has been screaming
since basically mid of 2021
that the impulse of growth and i always
talk about impulse so of course we're
gonna grow this year it's not going to
be a recession but is it going to be a
strong above trend growth with a strong
inflationary component at the end of
2022
i can't see that for sure until the
first half of this year i think we're
going on a trend basis down both in real
growth and in inflation all right so uh
you know i'm i'm i might actually be
more bearish than you alfonzo believe it
or not just because
you know i i look at the yield curve and
the the difference between the two and
the tenure basically as the amount of
runway that the federal reserve has to
tighten whether you're talking about
running off the balance sheet i mean
there's an enormous amount of u.s
treasuries coming due in 2022 so even if
they just let the balance sheet run off
it's going to be monumental in terms of
the equivalent of of tightening in
addition to the fact that they want to
start hiking rates i just we'll have to
wait and see you're right i think we'll
know a lot more six months from now but
uh
being somebody who wrote a book that was
the subtitle was why the federal reserve
is bad for america there was actually a
central banker that i liked even less
uh than
than american central bankers at the
time and that was mario draghi but i
have to say
as a prime minister
i don't know i think i like him better
what about you
so i think draghi is
has brought some institutional
credibility to
the prime minister office in italy we
have had some um difficulties in
asserting that
in on a g10 basis let's say over the
last decade
and draghi effectively is a person that
understands
what's wrong about italy he deeply
understands that
and
what he has been trying to achieve is
using the european recovery fund sources
which is basically great opportunity for
italy because this time we actually get
some proper funding at cheap levels from
the european union backed by
the netherlands finland germany so there
is some fiscal union exercise going on
initial baby steps but it's something
and drug has been tasked to try and use
that money as better as he can and
obviously
he has been relatively successful so far
in implementing projects because he
understands that this credit coming from
the eu needs to be used for productive
outlets
so he has been investing in digitalizing
for instance the
public administration in italy in making
sure the legislative processes are sped
up because it's really slow in italy
foreclosures and all of that
obviously all these policies uh should
be able to enhance productivity and
long-term growth in italy and attract
some foreign investments which is also
lacking a lot in italy he's been
definitely doing a decent job and it's
it's to me just fresh air to see a prime
minister that understands
uh what italy needs over the long term
and his advantage by the way is that it
doesn't want in my opinion nor needs to
be re-elected uh in 2023 he literally
cares about long-term benefits uh and
and reforms that italy needs rather than
you know getting some short-term
cyclical growth boost so i can be
re-elected in four years so i think it
will really benefit italy in five to ten
years for down from now
well i can't believe that i mean you say
these words but
there's a parallel and that's that jay
powell does not need his job
as the the chair of the federal reserve
at all his net worth speaks volumes and
he really is there just to serve his
country so for better for worse
at least he's holding the line on
socialism for the moment and that's the
best we can say and we can say mario
draghi makes a better prime minister
than he did as central banker um you
know i would love to i would love to
revisit a year from now
and maybe you'll have a bit different
background uh heck i'm in i'm in italy
in october let's try and make it happen
in person that would be so much fun
you shoot me a message and i'll make
sure that we see each other but are you
in austria or are you in italy and i
always make this joke if you're if
you're going to milan that yeah you're
in italy more or less are you in the
proper part of italy so south of italy
or i i tend to fly into rome so there
you have it okay i can do rome that's
done
wonderful well i want to thank you for
your time i really appreciate it i
recommend everybody follow you on
twitter you're just amazing and and the
the the newness of your analysis is
something that is so refreshing so i i
highly recommend uh following you and
understanding your work you put it out
there you do a great service to the the
future financial literacy thank you for
your time today
thank you actually education is my uh
my biggest thing here just trying to
deliver the knowledge to the people and
it's been a pleasure to to be here with
you great interview thank you thank you
grazie
[Music]